the joe biden white house is now facing
what is absolutely the biggest foreign
policy crisis of the still
relatively new presidency and
administration of the biden white house
there has been an absolutely terrible
terrorist attack in kabul afghanistan
this is part of
the broader context of joe biden
deciding to
make good essentially on the plan that
donald trump claimed to have now of
course donald trump ultimately did not
leave afghanistan essentially ran out of
time
but as far as we knew planned to leave
just like joe biden ultimately decided
to do and this is one of those areas
where if you are looking for
the sort of simplistic
black or white mannequin analysis of
what is going on in afghanistan there's
plenty of places to get that there's no
question about it and we've seen many of
those simplistic analysis analyses come
from the usual suspects the paid
political consultants on both right and
left for different reasons
we've seen them come from the
military-industrial complex friendly
generally
pro-war corporate media and by pro-war i
don't mean they want war per se
but they want conflict and salaciousness
and they know that military conflicts
generate ratings
and unfortunately all of those analyses
fall short and there's good and there's
bad and there's right and there's wrong
and it actually requires a little bit
more thinking in order to get something
approximating
a
view that considers a totality of what
is going on so we'll work backwards
thursday
two explosions happened
in an area right by the kabul airport
this is an airport that has become
a central location
in what is now taking place in
afghanistan which is
many people trying to leave there are
americans trying to leave
there are
locals trying to leave and seek asylum
or refugee status in the united states
and elsewhere as you are seeing the
taliban increasingly prevent people from
leaving to some degree and also now we
have introduced isis isis claiming
responsibility for the two explosions
these were suicide bombings as of this
morning the latest numbers were 182
people killed
including 169 afghan civilians and 13
members of the united states military
these are the first military casualties
in afghanistan since february of 2020
joe biden was
meeting the remains of the 13 deceased
american military members
when they arrived in the united states
over the weekend so let's go through
each item here because
you know it's actually kind of a bummer
i know that we're going to get really
simple black or white analysis from most
in the media the right is saying this is
all terrible because biden's incompetent
and trump would have done it great well
no he would have no no he would not have
some on the left are saying this was
carried out the wrong way biden was
wrong to leave or just this is perfect
and everything has been gone swimmingly
all of these takes fall short
joe biden was 100 correct to leave
afghanistan
doesn't change anything about that joe
biden was completely right to leave
afghanistan this does not mean
as a result of this terrorist attack
that we go back in
my preference right of course we we
might but i don't believe it means we go
back in but it does mean that joe biden
has a crisis to deal with here now for
those saying this crisis is what's
tanking joe biden's approval and this
crisis is going to prevent democrats
from winning in 2022 i disagree and i
disagree on both and we're going to go
into that more tomorrow the political
implications of this part of it is
voters have a very short-term memory
part of it is foreign policy actually
matters surprisingly little when it
comes to how people vote in elections in
the united states we'll get back to that
but the fact that after just a few days
of the united states pulling back
you have the taliban taking over and
then you have isis versus the taliban
this actually reinforces how completely
untenable our
involvement was in afghanistan we have
to stay forever in order to prevent this
that's proof that we shouldn't be
involved since the only way to keep
things even relatively calm
apparently is to stay involved
indefinitely it's not viable it's not
viable unless you believe in the united
states as the never-ending policeman of
the world which i don't that's not my
foreign policy view i thought it wasn't
the view of a lot of trumpists when it
was trump saying we're gonna get out of
there now all of a sudden those same
people have changed their mind i have
not changed my mind on this uh trump
should have left biden did leave obama
should have left but he didn't okay now
of course the right is going after joe
biden well yeah joe biden's a democrat
they're going to go after joe biden yes
this is a crisis but it would have been
the same crisis under donald trump we're
seeing all the normal experts on foreign
policy come forward
and say oh we should have stayed this is
a humiliation for biden
should have gotten out differently i
have a completely different perspective
without denying that this has not gone
well because it hasn't gone well
we rarely see presidents act this
decisively
in getting us out of a commitment around
the world
when presidents act decisively it's
usually to start an incursion and it's
considered patriotic by the right when
george w bush said on my order we have
started uh attacks in iraq after 9 11
and all of this
wow decisive and powerful well hold on a
second is it decisive and powerful to
start an incursion without actually
thinking through the consequences the
way george w bush did this is the
opposite but it is decisive joe biden
has drawn a line and is getting us out
of what george w w bush started what
barack obama didn't end what donald
trump didn't end biden is ending it in
the first year of his presidency and
that's good
and the situation has become very
chaotic and now joe biden has to figure
out what to do but remember that the
status quo before we left was not some
uh utopia
for the afghan population 200 000
afghans killed since we went in it's
been chaotic for years in afghanistan
but nobody was paying attention and now
suddenly people are saying it only just
got chaotic because joe biden decided to
leave that's wrong it got more chaotic
without a doubt and now we have pundits
and so-called experts saying the least
interesting things just stay stay for a
month stay for a year stay for another
20 years how is that even considered
remotely serious unless your view of
american foreign policy is uber
interventionist that's not my foreign
policy joe biden did a good thing by
leaving
left right and corporate media in their
own ways or slamming him but the
decision was the right one
now you have to figure out what to do
with the chaos all the same people who
ignored this for decades are now jumping
in like they've been paying attention
and saying we should be staying or we
should have left this way or we should
have like give me a break guys this is
the same media that mostly rode
willingly into george w bush's iraq war
who are now saying oh let's stay in
afghanistan give me a break there are
real problems
i don't understate for a second
the
dire situation that is happening in
afghanistan life lost tragedy but we've
had that for 20 years and barely a peep
from a lot of these same people now it's
a cynical
uninformed attempt to just go after joe
biden
joe biden deserves criticism in all of
this but leaving was the right decision
trump should have left obama should have
left resist the urge
to demand that something be either
perfect
or
terrible
okay reality is more complicated and
it's too complicated for the really
predictable boring hot takes that we are
seeing including from all sorts of
corporate media with various different
political stripes we're going to keep
talking about it this week by the way
one last thing i got a few emails from
people saying david why haven't you
talked about afghanistan
the first week of this crisis i was gone
i just i just wasn't here my guest hosts
talked about it since getting back i've
done nine segments on afghanistan this
today is number ten give me a break guys
find something else to complain about
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most innovative
shower head it uses only about half the
water that other shower heads do saving
you money helping the environment but
it's actually a lot more powerful than
other shower heads on the market it has
twice the coverage of other shower heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it only took a few minutes
to set up really easy and it's been a
totally different experience than any
other shower head i've used i can get in
and out of the shower way quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get completely
rinsed off so i was actually amazed that
it's only using about half as much water
nebia also offers a number of shower
accessories like shelves and curtains
which match perfectly with the design of
the shower head the shower head starts
at just 199 and you'll get 10 percent
off all nebia products when you go to
nebia.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
the link is right underneath this video